now as promised um i am going to take
this opportunity since i have the luxury
of time
uh to look at pascal's identity just a
little bit more closely because
maybe it was a while since you had a
look at uh
permutations and combinations and i
always think we say this over and over
and over again in class
that you shouldn't ever just accept
formulas i mean
i should say we shouldn't ever accept
formulas in mathematics
out there in the real world sometimes
you know what we just don't have time
to go through the derivation of
something and we're quite happy to
accept that a formula
will work on the basis of the data or
the situation that we've got
in front of us if the shoe fits right
but in mathematics one of the
design principles of the course as a
whole is that we don't give you
anything uh almost uh that you can't
prove yourself using the knowledge that
you have
so let's prove pascal's identity it's
not that much of a challenge if you're
willing to wrestle
with some uh factorial notation and
remember that stuff from last year so
let's have a go
what i'm going to do is i'm going to
prove this
this is my proof by considering the
left-hand side and then trying to
progress my way to the right-hand side
so what is
the left-hand side well let's just do a
straight substitution over here this is
where i'm starting from and in order to
get to the right hand side
that single binomial coefficient i
really have to untangle all this
factorial notation that we were trying
to avoid that we didn't need to work
with
in the proof by mathematical induction
but in order to do this proof
we do so how do we do this it's actually
going to be easier if we do this right
hand term first because it's the sort of
classical binomial coefficient it's n
factorial
divided by r factorial n minus
r factorial so that's our definition for
ncr
or you can see it written in this sort
of vertical bracket notation
and the reason why i highlight that is
because it makes it easier to work out
what the previous one is when it's got
this r pesky r minus 1 on the bottom
okay so for starters the numerator is
going to be the same
that makes sense we're in the same row
of pascal's triangle so you get an n
factorial on the top
then on the denominator what's going to
happen here well
you can see from this right hand term
here it's the r factorial so it's
whatever's on the bottom here
factorial i can do that here it's an r
minus 1
factorial and then i think i'm going to
need a teeny bit more space let's just
shuffle this over
then you would say okay it's going to be
how do i get this term it's your top
value here subtract your lower value
here your bottom value and then you
apply a factorial to that so what does
that look like
for this left-hand binomial coefficient
it's going to be n
there's the top term take away r minus
1. there's the bottom term
and that's going to be i'm going to
apply a factorial to that so you can see
there's going to be some um
some double negative business over here
i haven't still haven't given myself
enough space
so i'm going to want to expand that
fairly carefully so let's do that
on the next line get that n factorial
over there
and then i'm actually going to leave
myself even more space over here
i'm going to have my r minus 1 factorial
and then
n minus r plus 1 is what happens when i
distribute that
minus to the brackets so i get n
minus r plus 1 factorial
and then i haven't yet done anything to
this fraction over here all right
now the reason why i added a bit of
teeny extra space here
is that what am i going to try and do
here i've got two fractions
and clearly based on what i'm trying to
prove here clearly i want to convert
them into one fraction this is where i
want to arrive okay
now just think about this go back to
when you first learned about fractions
i need to get common denominators don't
i but there's just the additional
challenge of the fact that
these are very messy looking fractions
so let's start with an easy thing
okay you can see here i've got an r
factorial that i want
and i don't have an r factorial over
here
on my left hand fraction but it's not
difficult to turn an r minus 1
factorial into an r factorial for
instance
if i said okay i've got 4 factorial
and i want to turn it into 5 factorial
the way that i do that is by multiplying
it
by the next number along right so this
is my r factorial
just using an example of 5. here's my r
minus 1 factorial all i have to do is
multiply by
r so that's what i'm going to do on the
left hand fraction if i multiply through
by r here
of course you do it to the denominator
you better do it to the numerator
then what i've got now is this
whole term here will actually be
r factorial it's r times r minus 1
factorial
and i can do a very similar thing
working with whoopsy daisy
working with this part of the
denominator on the right if you have a
look and compare
this denominator here
uh or this factor of the denominator i
should say with this one here you can
see
there's an n minus r factorial and then
this is n minus r plus one it's just the
next term along it's a four factorial
five factorial situation
again so all i need to do here is
multiply by the next term along
and that will give me this denominator
so
what is the next term along its n minus
r
plus 1. if i multiply that on the bottom
i multiply
up the top and you can see now here if
you're looking at this carefully
this entire term here
or set of terms will combine together to
give me
n minus r plus 1 all factorial so that's
really good what's going to happen when
i put all of this together
on the left hand fraction it's going to
contribute n
factorial r and then the right hand
fraction is going to give me
n factorial and minus
r plus 1. okay so far
so good that's the numerator and then
what do i have
on the denominator
well the whole point of multiplying this
side by r was to give me r factorial so
i'm just going to write that and i'll
put it in blue so you can see where it
came from
and then the whole point in writing
multiplying this by n minus r plus 1
is to turn it into n minus r plus 1
factorial so i'll also write that in
orange so you can see
n minus r plus 1 factorial
okay this is uh this is progress right
now when you have a look at the
numerator here you can see
there's going to be some cancelling of
terms and this is very helpful
um for instance if i just have a look at
this n factorial r
and you've got the n factorial
multiplying by minus r
up the top there so this canceling is
going to be very helpful for me
let's go ahead and expand so we can see
it clearly n factorial r
out the front i'm getting n factorial n
minus n factorial r plus n
factorial that's a lot of n factorials
and then i haven't really changed
anything
on my denominator so i'll just pop it
down there again
okay so what's going to happen now
cancel cancel as i noticed before and
perhaps i shouldn't have expanded this
all the way because you can now see on
the numerator
there is this there's this common
factor of n factorial so i've got n
factorial
outside of n plus 1. and then on the
denominator i'm going to make a very
very minor change so you can see
where i'm going right have a look at
what i'm trying to prove i'm trying to
prove that this is
equal to n plus 1 cr which means i need
to find an
n plus 1 on the numerator and i also
need to find n plus 1 on the denominator
now it is there it's just kind of hidden
right this n minus r plus 1 i can
rearrange it so it's
n plus 1 take away r and that makes the
n plus 1
more visible so let's write that in a
more obvious way
i've got r factorial out the front and
then i'm just going to rearrange this
addition in here as
n plus 1 in brackets take away r
and that's a factorial all right i'm
only a couple of steps off now right
have a look at this numerator
this is the same trick i've been doing
but in reverse right a number factorial
multiplied by the next integer along the
line means
it's that whole thing factorial so what
have i got on the numerator
it's n plus 1 factorial
i don't need to change anything else on
the denominator
this is the binomial coefficient i was
after this
is n plus 1 c r
as required so as i mentioned before if
you're able to keep up with that
factorial notation
and the algebra and factorization in the
fractions you don't need to accept
someone telling you that pascal's
identity
is uh usable in this proof by induction
you can now see why and hopefully you're
convinced that this is a great way to
prove this result